Star Fox of mystery planets what a  pleasure to make your acquaintance my  fellow eternals  yeah it looks like we haven't seen the  last of Harry Styles in the MCU just yet  Styles made his MCU debut in the  eternals in a mid-credits scene where he  played Star Fox AKA arrows while  speaking with deadline Marvel producer  Nick Moore said quote we didn't cast  Harry for a tag Moore went on to say  there are more stories to be told with  that character he has an interesting  connection with Thanos they're half  brothers and share the same father he's  a complicated character but a really fun  character  I'll do it myself  MCU fans will remember that the Titan  Thanos was first introduced in a  mid-credits scene in 2012's The Avengers  going on to become the biggest villain  in the series through to 2019's Avengers  end game we'll have to wait and see what  the MCU has in store for Styles and  Starbucks  [Music]